HAVE A GREAT WEEKEND.
♪♪
>> WELCOME TO SPECIAL EDITION OF
HANNITY, TRUMP VERSUS THE
RADICAL LEFT.
WE START WITH PRETTY AMAZING
NEWS.
LOOK AT THIS.
I DOUBT THE MEDIA MOB WILL BE
FOCUSED ON IT.
BUT DONALD TRUMP ECONOMY JUST
BROKE ANOTHER HUGE RECORD.
FOR THE FIRST TIME IN RECORDED
HISTORY THE AFRICAN-AMERICAN
UNEMPLOYMENT RATE IN THE UNITED
STATES IS SDUN TO 5.5%.
THAT IS AN ALL-TIME LOW.
nd THAT'S NOT ALL.
THE UNEMPLOYMENT GAP BETWEEN
WHITE AMERICANS, BLACK
AMERICANS, IS ALSO AT A RECORD
LOW.
IN OTHER WORDS OUR ECONOMY IS
NOW HUMMING ON ALL CYLINDERS.
THANKFULLY WORKING FOR THE
ENTIRE FAMILY, ALL AMERICANS.
THE PRESIDENT'S TAX CUTS WERE A
HUGE SUCCESS.
THE PRESIDENT'S DEREGULATION,
THE NEW TRADE DEALS WITH MEXICO,
CAN DARK THE EUROPEAN UNION,
JAPAN A BIG WIN FOR AMERICAN
GOODS.
AND BY THE WAY, I EXPECT THAT
THE DEAL WITH CHINA IS GOING TO
BE FREE AND MORE FAIR AT THE END
OF THE DAY.
TOP IT ALL OFF, AMERICANS ARE
NOW SAFER.
LOOK AT THIS.
NATIONWIDE, VIOLENT CRIME IS
DOWN SIGNIFICANTLY BY A LOT.
AND BY THE WAY, CONSTRUCTION OF
THE WALL, THE BIGGEST UNREPORTED
STORY THIS WEEK, IS WELL
UNDERWAY.
THE PRESIDENT THIS WEEK, MEDIA
ISN'T FOCUSED ON IT, AFTER
SECURING THE $3.6 BILLION IN NEW
FUNDING, THE WALL IS GOING UP.
AS WE SPEAK.
THE VIDEO ON THE SCREEN IS
SHOWING THE PROGRESS AT THE
BORDER IN YUMA, ARIZONA, THAT'S
LAST WEEK ALONE, AND THE
PRESIDENT SAYING WE'LL GET 500
MILES BUILT BY THE END OF NEXT
YEAR.
NANCY PELOSI IS FURIOUS.
SHE VOWED TO CHALLENGE THE
FUNDING IN COURT.
PROBLEM IS THERE ARE LAWS THAT
WE HAVE CITED ON THIS PROGRAM AS
IT RELATES TO THE PRESIDENT,
LEGALLY BEING ABLE TO BUILD
WALLS AND BARRIERS TO STOP DRUG
CORRIDORS.
THAT LAW ALSO IS BACKED UP BY
SOMETHING CALLED THE
CONSTITUTION.
YOU SEE THE CONSTITUTION SAYS HE
IS THE COMMANDER IN CHIEF.
WE DON'T WANT THE 90% OF HEROIN
IN THIS COUNTRY THAT CROSSES
THAT BORDER TO ENTER.
WE CAN END THE TERRIBLE CYCLE OF
LOSING NEARLY 300 AMERICANS A
WEEK.
NANCY PELOSI, A LOT OF DEMOCRATS
SUPPORTEDED OBAMA'S WALL BUT
THEY DON'T SUPPORT TRUMP'S WALL.
THAT'S THEIR PROBLEM.
NANCY PELOSI DOESN'T AT ONE TIME
ADDRESS THE CRISIS AT ALL.
AND EVEN THOUGH TODAY IN HER OWN
STATE OF CALIFORNIA, LOOK AT
THIS, NANCY, IT'S LIKE WE SHOWED
A MILE FROM YOUR HOUSE, NEEDLES,
URINATION, DEFERCATION
PROBLEMS -- DEFICATION, AN
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANT ACCUSED OF
SHOOTING POLICE OFFICERS
APPREHENDED AFTER HIGH SPEED
PURSUIT.
MADAM SPEAKER, IF YOU ARE
SPEAKER IN NAME ONLY, IT WAS
PREVIOUSLY RELEASED, ALLEGEDLY
BECAUSE OF CALIFORNIA'S CITY AND
THEIR STATE SANTUARY LAWS.
IN OTHER WORDS AIDING AND
ABETTING THE PEOPLE THAT
COMMITTED KROIMS AND NOT HANDING
THEM OVER TO I.C.E. TO BE
DEPORTED.
IN MARYLAND, SIX ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS, ONE CONSIDERS
CITIZEN CHARGED IN THE STABBING
DEATH OF A 21-YEAR-OLD.
ACCORDING TO STATISTICS FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION DURING A TWO-YEAR
PERIOD, 4,000 MURERS CAN WERE
COMMITTED BY ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS
IN THIS COUNTRY.
100,000 ASSAULTS, CARRIED OUT.
30,000 SEXUAL CRIMES CARRIED
OUT.
EACH AND EVERY WEEK, HEROIN IS
KILLING, OPIOIDS ARE KILLING
APPROXIMATELY 300 AMERICANS.
90% OF HEROIN AND NOW FENTANYL
COMING IN THROUGH THE SOUTHERN
BORDER.
THIS IS A NATIONAL SECURITY
CRISIS.
THE PRESIDENT IS ABSOLUTELY
RIGHT TO MAKE THE BORDER A
PRIORITY.
AND THAT MEANS WE CAN PREVENT
THOSE DRUGS FROM GETTING INTO
THE HANDS OF AMERICAN KIDS.
THE PRESIDENT IS DEDICATED TO
IMPROVING THE QUALITY OF LIFE.
FOR ALL OF YOU CONSERVATIVES
THAT SAID HANNITY IS JUST
SUPPORTING THE PRESIDENT, THE
PRESIDENT DIDN'T GIVE UP ON THE
BORDER WALL HE CHANGED
STRATEGIES.
I'VE NOW BEEN PROVEN CORRECT.
THE MONEY HAS BEEN REALLOCATED.
IT IS LEGAL, CONSTITUTIONAL.
DESPITE SIGNIFICANT GAINS OF
AMERICANS AT HOME, YOU HAVE
DEMOCRATS, THEIR NUMBER ONE SUT
PORLTERS, CONTRIBUTORS, ALLIES,
THE MEDIA MOB ARE SEETHING WITH
ANGER AND PES SISM AND DESPAIR
AND HOPING FOR RECESSIONS,
OPENLY.
IF YOU WATCH THE TERRIBLE
CLIMATE, SEVEN-HOUR DISASTEROUS
MARATHON ON FAKE NEWS CNN.
YOU HEARD DEMOCRATS MOURNING THE
DESTRUCTION OF PLANET EARTH
BECAUSE OF PLASTIC STRAWS AND
CAPITALISM AND THE COME BULGES
ENGINE.
OTHERS ON THE LEFT USING THE
POLITICS OF RACE AND DIVISION TO
STOKE FEAR ALONG AMERICAN
VOTERS.
THAT IS A CLASSIC POLITICAL
TACTIC FROM DEMOCRATS AND THE
MEDIA MOB BUT IT'S MORE DEPRAVED
THAN EVER.
LOOK AT THIS, FORMER ESPN
COMMENTATOR JAMAIL HILL, CALLING
FOR VOLUNTARY RACIAL SEGREGATION
IN COLLEGE SPORTS TO, QUOTE,
DISRESULT THE REIGN OF AN
AMATEUR SPORTS SYSTEM THAT USES
THE LABOR OF, QUOTE, BLACK FOLKS
TO MAKE, QUOTE, WHITE FOLKS
RICH.
HILL IS USING THE POLITICS OF
RIS TO DIVIDETS COUNTRY ONE
PROMINENT AUTHOR OF STOKING
FEAR, AROUND ANYBODY WHO DARES
TO WEAR ANY RED HAT.
ANY RED HAT.
NO WRITING ON IT.
THE POLLSTER NOMINATED,
TWEETING, QUOTE, IF ANYBODY ELSE
IS MADE UNCOMFORTABLE BY ANYONE
WEARING ANY KIND OF RED BASEBALL
CAP LIKE I SEE ON MY HEART DOES
WEIRD BLEEP.
I FINALLY REALIZE THAT ONLY
SELLS TITLE INTEREST OR
WHATEVER.
MAYBE DON'T WEAR RED CAPS ANY
MORE, NORMAL PEOPLE?
I LIKE RED CAPS.
AND IF YOU'RE A BOSTON RED SOX
FAN AND CINCINNATI REDS FAN, IS
A PARENTALLY YOUR TEAM HATS ARE
SCARING THE SNOWFLAKES.
THEY MIGHT THINK ARE YOU A
SMELLY WALMART SHOPPERS.
I LOVE WALMART, THEY'RE GREAT.
YOU SAVE MONEY, GET THE SAME
PRODUCTS.
IRREDEEMABLE DEPLORABLES THAT
LIKE THE PRESIDENT, LIKES THE
SUCCESS WE'RE HAVING, LIKES THE
ECONOMY, CREATING JOBS AND
GETTING PEOPLE OFF FOOD STUMPS,
MAKING US ENERGY INDEPENDENT.
SADLY TRUMP DERANGEMENT SYNDROME
IS SO BAD TRUMP DONORS ARE BEING
TARGETED WITH HARASSMENT AND
PUBLIC SHAMING AND BOYCOTTS.
SARAH SANDERS NOW A FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR, WE EE GLAD TO HAVE
HER, A PRIVATE CITIZEN, STILL
CONFRONTED IN PUBLIC BY ANGRY,
PSYCHOTIC TRUMP-HATING LUNATICS.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> YOU'RE OUT OF THE
ADMINISTRATION NOW.
ARE YOU STILL TAKING HEAT WHEN
YOU GO OUT TO EAT?
>> SOMETIMES.
YOU KNOW, USUALLY DEPENDS WHERE
I AM IN THE COUNTRY.
BACK HOME IN ARKANSAS, THINGS
ARE SO FAR PRETTY EASY AND
WELCOMING.
>> HOW ABOUT NEW YORK CITY.
>> IT'S HIT OR MISS.
I HAVE NOT BEEN ASKED TO LEAVE
ANY RESTAURANT BUT EVERY ONCE IN
A WHILE YOU HAVE?
WHO COMES UP TO SAY SOMETHING.
>> LIKE WHAT?
>> NASTY TO YOU.
>> Sean: THE VILIFICATION HAS TO
STOP.
NO ONE DESERVES TO BE HARASSED.
THE MOB AND THE MEDIA STOKING
ALL OF THIS RESENTMENT.
THEY HATE TRUMP EVERY SECOND,
MINUTE, HOUR, OF EVERY 24-HOUR
WEEK, EVERY WEEK, EVERY MONTH,
EVERY YEAR.
RUSSIA, RUSSIA, STORMY, STORMY,
RACIST, RACIST, IMPEACHMENT,
IMPEACHMENT.
SHARPIE, SHARPY, THE LATEST.
NONSTOP HYSTERIA OVER DRAWING A
MAP.
ACCORDING TO NEWS BUSTERS ON
WEDNESDAY, FAKE NEWS CNN AND,
YES, MSNBC, THE CONSPIRACY
NETWORK, DEDICATED A WHOPPING
145 MINUTES OF AIR TIME TO
SHARPIE COVERAGE AND ANALYSIS.
AND OF COURSE THE HYSTERICAL
REPORTING IN AN ATTEMPT TO MAKE
THE PRESIDENT LOOK BAD.
WHAT THEY DO.
THEY'RE THE ONES WHO APPEAR
DETACHED FROM REALITY, THE ONES
THAT PUSHED EVERY LIE,
CONSPIRACY FOR 2 1/2 YEARS.
THE MEDIA MOB NOT KNOW HOW
INSANE THEY LOOK?
APPARENTLY NOT.